[Music]
welcome to the reason Roundtable your
weekly podcast from the libertarian
magazine that has no trouble at all
avoiding dinner dates with actual Nazis
I am Matt Welch joined by Nicholas B
Peter suterman and Catherine mangyu Ward
happy webathon week colleagues howdy hey
Matt happy Cyber Monday all right right
getting the cyberon
um I want to remind everyone up top uh
please keep teeing up those ask us
anything emails
for our special bonus episode that we're
taping uh Wednesday for the uh for the
webathon have you mentioned the webathon
it's happening it's it's going to be
happening anytime soon it's our annual
fundraising Drive
um and uh so send your stuff uh personal
uh broad system-wide whatever address is
Roundtable at reason.com all right
Elizabeth Nolan Brown's morning roundup
post uh today carries the headline we
want freedom Chinese protests reflect
frustration with countries continuing
covid restrictions
we are seeing here in November 2022 the
biggest scenes of public protest and
unrest in mainland China since the
Tiananmen Square massacre of June 1989
or the run-up thereof this rare recent
instance of public bravery was touched
off by a fire in a reportedly sealed up
apartment complex in urum key and I
apologize for no nothing in that
pronunciation uh killed at least 10
people injured a bunch more it's kind of
hard to imagine a more poignant and apt
demonstration of zero covid
authoritarianism then literally locking
people up uh to die in order to pursue a
collective goal that is literally uh
unachievable protesters throughout China
have been chanting we want freedom
they've been holding up empty signs to
thwart's attempts at censorship about
what they can't put on signs and
occasionally even calling for the
resignation of Xi Jinping though we'll
see how long that particular plot line
lasts Superman let's start with you what
does this uh very uh unsettling and
moving and kind of crazy conflict tell
us about China's covet policies it tells
us that even the most powerful strictest
largest authoritarian governments in the
world is unable to fully restrict its
citizens freedoms at a certain point
they have enough they've had enough and
they're going to start protesting so I I
think it's worth just talking a little
bit about what what Chinese citizens
have been going through for the last
three years or so they've been going
through something you know something
that is often referred to lockdowns but
lockdowns that are just more or less
unheard of in the Western World
certainly after the first couple of
months of covet here the the kinds of
lockdowns that they're experiencing are
just insane so you mentioned that they
are sealing off buildings and that just
happens sometimes basically without
warning someone or some group of people
will get sick and there are videos out
there you can see where they where you
see uh these Public Health authorities
coming in and and and they're like you
know they're using the the welding
machines you know to to seal off
buildings they're putting up um they're
putting up barriers throughout cities
right so that people can't go places and
this will again just happen totally
arbitrarily totally without warning
there will be announcements you know in
the morning that oh wait no one is
allowed to go anywhere for four days but
there's also just a lot of little stuff
even in places that aren't under
something like a a really hardcore
lockdown um everyone has to test all the
time and there is a an app that they
have to log into where they have either
a green yellow or red rating after their
testing but it's not even clear what
would give them a yellow or a red rating
and sometimes if you get yellow you have
to quarantine and sometimes you you
don't and it's totally it it's totally
mysterious how all of it works and so
the feeling in in China from everything
that I've read uh there's some very good
accounts in the New York Times that have
informed my understanding of this the
feeling in China is one of total
powerlessness because the citizens are
not even being given sort of clear rules
in a clear system that's basically oh
here's here's how you do it this is what
what we're gonna expect and then it's
stable
instead they're being told you just have
to comply with whatever we come up with
on any given day and we're not going to
explain ourselves to you at all and
people are being left it's so I mean in
this case you know we've we saw probably
people die because the response was slow
and because the building had been locked
down but people are being left without
food in their Apartments because they're
suddenly being told you cannot leave
your apartment for three or four or
seven days at a time and then when they
can't leave their apartment they can't
get food or because other people can't
leave their Apartments food deliveries
are are not being able to be made to
grocery stores and so people are just
living under a completely insane sort of
Public Health authoritarian state right
now and they've been living that way for
three years and I think you know in some
ways the most poignant part of this to
me obviously like the worst stuff is the
people dying the people not being
allowed to you know to move around
people being sort of totally trapped in
their homes
but there's it's the little things that
are that are in some ways less important
that are kind of poignant to me not just
the food and stuff not just people not
being able to meet with each other but
there were there were chants of people
saying you know give us freedom we want
to see movies because they haven't been
able to see movies they haven't been
able to go to theaters in some cases you
know not quite for a full three years
but for much of the last three years and
people are just being denied the basic
pleasures of daily life in addition to
being told that your lives are now just
going to be completely structured and
run by the Communist Party Catherine
what are some thoughts that you've had
in uh watching
um the protests unfold in between bouts
of extreme physical therapy
there have been a couple of things that
have caught my eye the first is
um I really do have this
um kind of
warm feeling toward the protesters which
I don't know what to do with right I
mean you know you see all this social
media activism you see people you know
posting on their Instagram story from
the safety of Brooklyn and um that feels
like almost counterproductive to me
somehow I have this sort of very strong
feeling of wanting to do something
tangible to support those people and
there are some Charities there are some
ways to donate but I'm struck by how
tertiary that is how how sort of removed
that is in the end it's just like these
people putting their bodies in the
street in front of a literal or implied
gun and that's it that's where the work
is that's the only place the work can be
um and so I find myself really thinking
about you know how what can I do besides
go rah-rah from the safety of my uh
physical therapy and it's not it's not
clear
it's not clear to me how I mean you know
they're like I say there are links I've
looked at them but they also don't look
very effective it's you know some
third-party charity that's going to
spend all the money on on something
other than
directly supporting those protesters
because in the end it's just their
bodies versus the state and I I felt
that way about the uh protests in Iran
as well the protests in Hong Kong a
couple years back it's just that's
really striking to me the other tidbit
is um there was a point where the
protesters were instructed to stop
saying
um anti-lockdown pro-freedom slogans and
so they just started chanting and mass
in favor of the lockdowns but like
obviously brutally ironically in a way
that was almost more powerful and that
at least appeals to my I don't know I
feel like that has big Gen X energy and
I like it a lot like we demand to be
locked down they scream in the streets
with the you know
authoritarian police you know staring
them down love that
um love the Sass on it but um but yeah I
mean this is this is the nightmare this
is the fever dream of of what an out of
control authoritarian state does in the
in a public health emergency we don't
have to we don't have to read dystopian
fiction it's just right there on the
news Catherine it sounds like you're
looking for a more effective altruism I
sure am Matt gosh I wish someone could
do some some like thinking about this
and then maybe fund institutions and
individuals to support effective
altruism like I want to know how to buy
bed nets for the Chinese protesters Matt
uh Nick speaking of really lame attempts
to make American domestic politics out
of something that's happening abroad uh
people are obviously doing that right
now in the uh kind of domestic coveted
Wars they're using China as an example
either as you know C this is what you
people have been wanting and that's why
you're bad or uh that's a ridiculous
comparison to make is there any is it
appropriate to even bring up Chinese uh
severe authoritarianism in the context
of the American domestic argument over
covet policies
all right yeah sure no I wouldn't
um you know zenip tufetsky said it it
wasn't because uh because no one is
replicating that type of actual policy
here in America and we're just sort of
comparing a police state to try to
bludgeon our enemies
yeah they uh you know maybe we should
have an amnesty for uh the Chinese
government uh when it comes to uh covet
policy
um I think it makes sense to talk about
it and to publicize it and to uh also
you know push our own government to do
whatever it can to actually you know
affect some kind of positive change if
we believe in diplomacy if we believe in
trade if we believe in all sorts of
things you know uh one uh question that
certainly came to the fore during the
Trump years and it persists through the
Biden years and when you think about
something like Ukraine and Russia there
is no sense uh among the American people
incl and by that I mean people in our
class political journalists do we have
any idea what if any kinds of diplomatic
um considerations are in play here plus
trade et cetera I mean we just have no
idea under Trump people assume nothing
was happening wasn't always true when
you look at something like the Abra
Abraham Accords but there was a
generalized understanding that he's
incompetent in a buffoon under Biden
it's something else but like I don't
know you know what are we doing I
watched uh over the weekend uh Tony
fauci uh talked about how you know one
of the problems why China isn't sharing
information with us or with the who is
because Trump was so anti-china right
out of the box and the uh host actually
pushed back and said you know that
hasn't seemed to change at all China's
actions under uh Biden which is a good
question and you know what we're seeing
here is an authoritarian repressive
regime acting exactly the way that they
have been doing for the past 15 or 20
years and certainly in the past decade
or so since she really emerged as the
supreme leader so uh yeah I think it
makes total sense to be talking about
China I think it also makes sense to
extrapolate from China to what America
got right or wrong about this and
um you know there's situations aren't
exactly analogous but this it is a
better response to covid to get good
vaccines out part of what's going on in
China is that they're still pushing
their shitty State uh vaccine that has
like a 50 percent you know rate of like
helping people as opposed to something
much higher than that but uh it's much
better to have a bunch of vaccines out
in circulation that allow individuals to
set their own risk levels and go about
their lives how they see fit without
endangering other people or being
endangered so
um you know that's good and I think it's
probably worth talking yeah there's the
the difference between kind of a
mitigation uh strategy and an
eradication strategy is uh is going to
become even more uh Stark over the
coming weeks as the pandemic undoubtedly
is going to spread in China and and you
can't just make it the thing go away uh
it's it's kind of it's kind of uh crazy
that that's still a way to do it this
time on of unvaccinated people including
old people in China that's just not
going to be a very good recipe speaking
of the fauci um interview and just that
one specific narrow point about Trump
calling it The China virus and
everything because Trump goes in a bunch
of different directions and did
certainly as president
um people might have already forgotten
but his initial response that China was
nailing it they were doing a great job
in the first several weeks before he had
then pivoted to calling it The China
virus so I'm not sure uh you know if we
can attribute Chinese policies to uh
What uh what Trump said Peter fauci also
said
um in a weekend interview and when is he
going to stop doing the interviews
who's going to retire I could have sworn
he's like going to the retirement
All I Want For Christmas is about you to
stop doing it
he's not old enough yet Matt the
mandatory retirement age is now 99. but
you say that's good Nick from last week
I want to bring that one up again I
think it's uh you know what uh I think
we should be increasing the minimum age
of participation to like 45 to 50. just
keep that one thing that he said
suiterman uh was that he was asked like
hey uh you know it's a uh that's getting
cold and flu season again are we gonna
think about maybe closing the schools
and he's like I don't know maybe we're
gonna need to sorry for that um uh close
the schools uh which is a nightmare that
I thought that we'd had like uh
progressed from but there was actually
quite a few over the weekend reminders
that covet policies still can err on the
Restriction side or at least the ooga
booga side
um not just fouches saying that but
uh Washington D.C public schools
required a positive or A negative uh
covet test before opening their doors to
people just today uh believe it or not
and then uh American Federation of
teachers uh Union uh president Randy
Weingarten uh tweeted out that we're
facing a quote triedemic
flu RSV and covin triedemic
uh so uh I mean so I wonder if she has
any English teachers like in her Union
that could help with that yeah and like
if if
say a High School junior turned in a
paper two years ago four years ago with
the word triedemic in it how would the
high school English teacher have felt
about that
it depends if you're talking about
sexuality or not I suppose uh one uh one
uh question just uh maybe in a lightning
round way is so this is sort of a uh
it's like uh the umpteenth version of
some slasher movie of this uh these uh
restrictions or threatened restrictions
coming back in uh but did anyone face in
our blue Coastal decadent enclaves uh
any uh lingering examples of uh coveted
restrictions Peter did you over the long
holiday weekend
none Catherine I I have just been like
remarking on how it's like it's the end
of like the beginning of this year we
had mask mandates in Washington DC
through I think the end of February and
it and you know over the past six months
or so it's been basically gone uh
Catherine did you face any in physical
therapy
I did not uh well I mean I've been
partaking of quite a lot of Medical
Services since my uh e-scooter knee
smashing incident and I gotta say masks
at everything still
um and mandatory masks and everything or
or no in healthcare settings right like
it's not you know I'm not I don't know
what the uh law is actually in DC at
this point but certainly the universal
custom
is to wear a mask full-time in any
doctor's office um you know I took my
kids for their annual checkups masks
like the the pediatrician basically
didn't see their faces for their annual
checkups right and uh my physical
therapy is all done in a mask and uh
there's I don't think strong reasons to
do that this year that didn't exist say
four years ago during flu season but
here we are also definitely a lot of
chatter in DC because the DC public
schools required kova tests to return
after Thanksgiving I exercised my uh
right of school choice a while back and
my kids are not in DC public schools
anymore I wish other people had those
same rights of school choice but instead
they all scrambled around for dumb
covert tests which they took which
didn't actually approve anything because
it was easy to fake them or not do them
or whatever and no one was actually
paying attention I suppose I've had to
wear a mask while taking my dogs to the
vet a couple of times in the past few
months but that's about it like this is
that is for sure our new normal and and
I can't you know it's it's not insane
on some level to be like hey the places
where we keep the germs maybe wear masks
there like we store the germs in these
these hospitals syndrome
on the other hand it's absolutely
annoying infuriating and I think
produces lower levels of care do you
have to mask suderman's dogs what about
you Matt Matt what about you we never
ask you the question and this was
supposed to be a lightning round Matt
Welsh did you encounter like that mom
who's never in the holiday photos you're
so sad that's uh that's uh that's uh
project hashtag goals it's like Hattie
Carroll Hattie Carroll he does it no I
mean I traveled internationally recently
and and uh and you know uh did things in
public all over New York and I mean you
had monkeys did not have monkey pox
openly all over your face and nobody it
hasn't been a factor at all and it's
just been like people are masking
discretionarily when for instance their
seven-year-old kid is coughing a lot um
seems like a good idea but no one's um
no one's being banged up about it we had
coveted in the household a few weeks
back and so you know the the preschool
or whatever Elementary School
that the kid goes to college
says yeah put on a mask for the first
couple of days afterwards for your close
contact but it was not a big deal it's
not every word not at the vet not at the
doctor's office thankfully and even
though the few places left around
that have like oh you got to put on a
mask here
um actually you know the one the old the
only places and this is uh other people
I I know have found the same thing is
that uh the most common site in New York
City to say oh you no masks are still
required and they'll hand them out to
you bookstores bookstores of all places
so that's uh there's a fair amount of
them yeah perfect
cultural perspective and yeah not a lot
from an epidemiological thankfully not
the Strand America's greatest bookstore
except for now uh Norm McNally Jackson
on uh print stream which I highly or
spring stream uh Nick have you
experienced this in police Matt I did uh
yes I went to the doctor for a uh
mysterious follow-up visit uh not none
of us was clear what it was a follow-up
too maybe it was a Prelude visit I don't
know but uh like Catherine they gave uh
everybody in the waiting room masks that
were not n95 but not your you know
typical shitty fake mask or the uh
Alyssa Milano crocheted mask that was
making the rounds on Twitter
um after uh this week and when she
denounced Tesla because Elon Musk is a
is a fascist and she talked about how
she got rid of her Tesla and bought a
Volkswagen electric car instead because
she doesn't want to be identified with
somebody who's a fascist car maker uh
and she was wearing a crochet mask at a
lot of people close up but they gave us
these masks that it wasn't clear how to
use them and it was like they shrunk in
the sun over the past year of non-use
because everybody like nobody could fit
them over their faces I mean it was
really like you could have one on your
nose and maybe one on your chin uh and
then in the doctor's room the nurses and
doctors were like yeah don't bother
we don't need I don't know how many of
you have been to Florida recently maybe
all of us
um uh depending on on families but uh as
per usual during the pandemic the
difference between Florida and uh and
everywhere else is pretty Stark when it
comes to that Peter do you think that uh
being from Florida
um are is the kind of Landing point of
our covet policy just that in places
like Washington DC that vote 90
Democratic you're still going to have
um in my mind ridiculous policies like
mandatory covet tests at the
Thanksgiving holidays and the rest of
America is like what are you people even
talking about
yeah I think that lingering coveted
restrictions to the extent that they
exist in the United States are mostly
going to express themselves as a
political affectation
yeah uh Captain there was a Nick
mentioned in amnesty earlier before
which may have been a reference to uh
your uh uh sexy American girlfriend
Emily oster's controversial pay uh piece
in I think the Atlantic three or four uh
weeks ago
in which she kind of sensibly in my mind
um said hey look we need to offer uh an
amnesty not to necessarily to Public
Health officials that's how everyone
read it but just to human beings who
early on in the pandemic uh in when we
didn't have a lot of knowledge uh
advocated X that would be sort of in a
restrictionist point of view and that
you know if people come out and say hey
look as we learned more we changed our
views and we should be cool with that uh
she was immediately denounced uh as is
her want
um for uh opening her mouth on this
um uh but isn't part of that like the
the the
controversy over that because the those
people who actually did have some power
in this and actually did Advocate things
that weren't right and maybe even they
knew they weren't right but they were
using it for their own narrow purposes
like to try to to keep masks from being
raided uh early on in the pandemic that
we haven't heard them say hey look my
bad we were so I'm sorry we went too far
um is there an amnesty possible when
people don't fess up their wrongdoing
yeah I'm not sure I would have chosen
the word amnesty like I like this idea
from Emily uh and by the way I want to
say like the the follicle that you are
building for me on this podcast is just
like me and Emily Oster and like Jeff
Flake like living happily together or
whatever used to be Elon but I'm not
sure that he's really there anymore it's
you know it's a dynamic system
um so you know I think that the trouble
with the word amnesty is that a lot of
people hate that word for good reasons
right like when it's applied to
immigration it's understandably uh
controversial
um and you know I I think that the way
that I read that post was that she was
just saying like can we can we chill
right like can we like acknowledge that
we are humans that people screwed up
that um in almost every case people were
acting with the best of intentions
um and that just some people got it
wrong I I think the idea of this is like
you know
um some mumbo-jumbo therapy nonsense but
like we can't control when the people
who screwed up apologize enough I'm not
in charge of fauci's tone for his
apology what I can't control is like am
I gonna just keep losing my mind about
this forever and ever in like a
recursive way that ruins my life or am I
gonna chill am I just gonna say we
learned some lessons I'll fight harder
next time you'll maybe think twice next
time or vice versa depending on which
position you think you're in and
um and we can move on and I think you
know to me that is the biggest
difference between what went wrong in
the US and what is going on in China
right now it seems very very very clear
to me in China that
um this is an authoritarian State taking
advantage of a public health emergency
to further expand its powers Peter
mentioned the red orange or the red
yellow green ratings those are also
being used for Political Criminals like
your coven status changes when they find
you at a protest and that kind of thing
understandably makes people scared it
didn't for the most part really really
didn't happen here maybe it could happen
here but it mostly didn't right we talk
and write and think a lot about the
abuse of emergency powers and I think it
is totally right to call that out on the
part of the state but I agree that what
Emily was trying to say was hey we gotta
we gotta get along as a country we gotta
figure out how to keep talking to each
other and living together or else things
are going to get worse not better and I
think she's right
one of my uh perhaps biggest lamentation
about the midterm elections that just
happened is that the Michigan Governor
uh Gretchen Whitmer uh won pretty
decisively
um or at least did not lose
um which I wanted her to do
um because she was one of the worst
offenders when it came to issuing
emergency problem proclamations in the
face of kovid uh just randomly declaring
this aisle open and this one closed in
uh in big box stores
um was really one of the worst like you
couldn't buy shovels but you could buy
rakes but only if the rakes were like a
certain diameter and it was it was just
the craziest set of rules you've ever
heard amazingly bad but unfortunately
the Republican Party in the state of
Michigan throughout the gubernatorial
level
um a lot of Statewide levels
um uh had some of their very worst
trumpy candidates uh out there uh Tudor
Dixon ran against Whitmer and so
Michigan not only a delivered Whitmer
the state house but went uh more
democratic than it has in a really long
time almost like inching away from um
its normal status of being a swing state
it's almost as if the FBI wasn't content
with trying to get a kidnapping plot
against Whitmer but they uh helped the
idiot Republicans elect the most Trump
favorite candidates who couldn't win a
real primary much less if Whitmer would
would have lost which she did not at all
or come close to it uh we would have had
a a much uh cleaner or more interesting
story about the out limited but real a
role that uh locked down or non-lockdown
policies played in the election
um a couple of the governors who won
re-election by the most impressive
margins were some of the more
comparatively open Governors Ron
DeSantis obviously Brian Kemp perhaps a
little bit less obviously and Jared
Polis too in Colorado as a Democrat he's
probably the most kind of open Democrat
and he thumped to re-election Victory
and we had Joe Lombardo uh oust
an incumbent in Nevada Steve sisalak who
and that was the number one issue by far
was sis lack's lockdown of the uh Las
Vegas strip Kathy hokel
um that wasn't the number one issue here
is probably the number three issue in
New York but New York went really
Republican compared to where it was
before
um and that was at least a little bit
part of it but the Whitmer thing kind of
screws that up as a storyline all right
you know if I may just to return to
China where we started with this one of
the things that is good about
publicizing the the protests there which
are unbelievable I mean it's like you
know the idea when you look at
protesters in places like Hong Kong and
other parts of China plus Iran where
they face absolute you know reprisals
prison torture death
um it's amazing but we should be
promoting that as much as possible we
have a great video coming out uh
tomorrow that Jim Epstein put together
uh the human rights foundation's recent
Oslo Freedom Forum uh meeting in New
York where they're trying to promote the
idea of activist dissidents in
authoritarian countries speaking up and
drawing attention to it and one of the
things that Thor Halverson the the head
of uh human rights Foundation talks
about is that in every successful revolt
and they always ultimately come from
within the country
um you know there's a point where the
guys with the a gun so [ __ ] it I'm not
doing this anymore
and that is a response to mass protests
by their fellow citizens we saw that
happen throughout Eastern Europe and the
former Soviet Union uh at the collapse
of that and hopefully you know all of
these protests including the protests in
China right now internally are pushing
that country to a place where the the
people with the guns you know who are
the ones who have to be there in order
to enforce authoritarianism are like
[ __ ] it I'm all right we're going to get
to our uh listener email of the week
here in a moment but first a word from
our sponsor betterhelp online therapy
friends the holiday season which we're
already lumbering through can be one
logistical and emotional Minefield after
another family travel shopping workplace
booze fests
shorter days colder nights sure you
could try blundering through the
darkness once again or maybe this year
get yourself and your brain a guide to
help you navigate the tricky bits
that's where better help the world's
largest therapy service comes in better
help has matched three million people
with professionally licensed and vetted
therapists
it's an affordable service 100 online no
waiting rooms and it's super flexible if
you don't like your first match swap
them out for another until you find the
right fit listeners who act right now
can get 10 off their first month just go
to betterhelp.com Roundtable fill out a
brief questionnaire and find your guide
through the looming Darkness that's
better h-e-l-p like Paul's Boutique go
there today you'll be glad you did all
right reminder send your queries to
round table at reason.com including for
our special forthcoming ask us anything
bonus episode this week in honor of our
annual webathon fundraiser and if I can
just add uh when the webathon goes live
which I believe is tomorrow
please note that the little online form
thingy has a section for feedback what
you like what you've done what brought
you here it's a fine opportunity to
mention I don't know whatever like you
know like podcasts you think is pretty
cool or whatever it's fine
to just feedback it's great uh anyway
this week can I tell people about some
of the cool stuff they might get if they
donate holy cow yes could I do that
would that be okay with you you can um I
this wasn't in the spread buddy um I am
the script uh so
one good thing about the webathon is
that uh it starts on giving Tuesday
which is tomorrow uh reason is 51c3 so
your donations are tax deductible always
take money from the tax man
um if you give us money you get stuff at
the smaller levels you get a stress ball
which feels right you get a reason
calendar you get Twitter Facebook shout
outs that kind of thing a little bit
more money you get an NPR style tote bag
and you can choose one that says
taxation is theft if you're on team
Catherine uh at the hospitals really
like an NPR bag then it's exactly like
NPR should be
um and at the higher levels you get
lunch with an editor it could be me it
could be any of these guys on this
podcast it could be a random other
reason editor that you just are fan
Girling or boying on
and uh at the highest levels you get an
invitation to come hang out with all of
us at reason weekend if you are a first
timer so um there's a bunch of cool swag
you should give for the joy of
supporting an important publication that
you love but also
for the cool stuff
thank you Catherine
um this week's email comes from uh one
of our beloved listeners Norm Benson AKA
at Tim burati on the Twitter machine
who writes us in a way that's not
uncommon with our ask us anything style
questions which tend to be a little bit
more jocular depending more pointed also
uh anyways uh Norm Benson writes I have
found what is for me a paradox I want to
hear what you all think of it but I am
primarily interested in hearing from
Catherine
since she is a woman
and women account for some 51 percent of
the population I thought that there's
gonna be no math my personal Paradox is
this how is it that women are 51 of the
market and yet cannot find women's pants
with pockets free Minds free markets no
potemkin pockets thank you Norm uh I
should say that uh uh I've been ordered
to direct this question not at Catherine
but at Peter suderman Peter why am I
forwarding this to you
I mean I have thoughts but Peter's
thoughts are actually better than mine
on this so he should go first at least I
do not think that my thoughts are better
than Catherine's however
I just wanna I wanna introduce equally
valid I want to introduce a an idea to
this podcast
and that idea is fanny packs
fanny packs do you guys remember fanny
packs were you alive in the 1980s and
the 1990s fanny packs are like a belt
but with a little bag
kind of it's kind of a belt bag
situation and you can wear them on your
face you could wear them on your fanny
and put stuff in them if you don't have
pockets people used to wear them to like
theme parks
they thought they were safer
right like you you wouldn't get your
wallet stolen or you lose your watch on
a roller coaster if you're wearing a
fanny pack
and because people ultimately learn I
thought
by the end of the 1990s people weren't
wearing fanny packs anymore because they
looked ridiculous
but now if you walk around Washington DC
you can see all of these young people
many of them women wearing fanny packs
but not on their on their tushes
not on their fannies they're just
wearing them around their shoulders like
it's it's like a belt it's like you you
know that thing that Chewbacca wears
that's like his like ceremonial like
around him just like that but but with a
pocket and if you add that to a dress
then it's like your dress has
uh you know pocket accessory and so the
market may not provide pockets in the
way that that our our writer
what's the once the market to provide
but the market has provided Pockets that
you can add on to a pocketless piece of
clothing
uh Catherine after or before we fire
Peter we're gonna need to fire you for
thinking that that was a good idea I was
gonna say I'm sorry I apologize for
nothing the word Peter was looking for
was either sash or maybe Ben bandolier I
think but um
um right so I I will try to keep it
short but there's actually a super
interesting history here the fanny pack
is a reversion to the medieval pocket
mean which is uh people used to wear a
little pouch on the outside of their
clothes because they that if that's how
people had pockets
uh that little pouch on the outside of
your clothes became a hidden bag inside
your skirts for women and women actually
used to have like really baller Pockets
like you could keep like a whole you
know lunch in one and like all your
worldly Goods in the other because there
was a lot of skirts right the trouble is
then skirts got skinny and then there
was no room for Pockets then we got the
little cute bag also
um the patriarchy was like a lady
shouldn't do work or handle money so
that was for sure a problem and
sometimes the patriarchy does get in the
way of markets my man timarotti uh like
that's a real thing
um markets don't do justice they just do
what people want and sometimes what
people want isn't what they say they
want or what they think they want and
things get real complicated anyway all
this is by way of saying
uh we are now I think going backwards to
the the external pocket either in fanny
pack form or of course the purse right
like the actual Market answer to women
want to carry stuff but also want their
pants to look nice is just the darn
purse I know that's not a very exciting
answer but like there it is
um and uh you know also there is now a
valuable friend making social signaling
mechanism which is that if a lady tells
you that she likes your dress and then
you can say it has pockets then you
become best friends and so in a way
isn't the real free markets the friends
we made along the way
are you wearing pants uh Catherine I'm
not going to answer that question and
I'm also calling it do they have to do
they have pockets actually I'm wearing
leggings with pockets because the market
did provide all right there I mean this
I want to go to the root of the question
because we're radicals for Capital I
mean for reals I put into amazon.com
leggings with pockets because uh yeah
and then I got them so it was great some
of them have them some of them don't
same with sweatpants but like women's a
lot of women's pants have pockets Matt
you would know that from your infrequent
but regular Friday nights when you go
out yeah
um Nick um I want you to enter wait
you're a Friday night guy no I was a
third honestly I was a 39 guy uh but
that was a long long time ago Peter um
uh Nick I was just hoping we could
coordinate we cannot uh we I'm never
gonna coordinate with someone who points
to Washington DC as the incubator of
fashion
um that's this is that's just a deal
breaker before we even get started Nick
I want you to enter y'all I'll give you
some door options door number one uh
just says Pop-Tarts on it uh door door
number door number two
I'll take to our number the uh ongoing
uh Nick Gillespie thesis one of your
best
um that uh so many uh issues especially
revolving uh pregnancy and childbirth
are it's all big scam to try to keep
women down and how to how does the pant
pocket fit into that or the skirt pocket
fit into that and then door number three
is uh just make fun of Peterson uh yeah
I'm gonna go off uh off the board Matt
and merely say yeah this Peter and I can
discuss this for hours if we want but
over the week it's not my uh consumption
because I actually saw something good
and worth going to but I did in the past
week I saw wakanda forever and I left
the Thinker the theater thinking it only
felt like forever that um
that should have been half as long and
it might so to bring this back to the
question you know who else doesn't have
pockets
superheroes like Spider-Man doesn't have
pockets in those Underoos right and
that's why Batman has a utility belt
which is basically just a superhero
fanny pack
um all right let's just move on
um
it is I feel like we just did a a new ad
up freeform adaptation of Deliverance uh
for people on a journey to the Heart of
Darkness and let's just not talk about
that sounds right let's talk instead
about Peter and Catherine's favorite
topic uh which is the World Cup Soccer
Tournament the quadrennial occasion for
billions of people to yell and scream at
their television sets and to drink in
fraternal uh uh and uh and contested
manners uh this one is being hosted in
the Persian Gulf State of Qatar also
Qatar also whatever however you want to
pronounce it to make you happy I'm all
in favor of it the big yeah yeah
they're trying that you know I say that
a lot about their speakers I understand
that not everyone is into the sports
ball but the world is
um and this is a big uh Tableau I don't
know what that word means either
um so let's do another lightning round
and yes I will participate nicolespie
um of any news bit related to the World
Cup related to the sporting spectacle
that you find of Interest Superman why
don't you start since it's going to
obviously be about booze yeah they
banned beer in the stadiums which is
that's like as far as I can tell that's
actually worse than Banning soccer at a
soccer game like the whole point of a
soccer game or football or whatever
we're supposed to call it the whole
point is to be in the Stadium's drinking
beer like the the sports playing is
somewhat incidental to the beer drinking
and so they banned the main thing and
that's really funny because one of the
maybe the single biggest sponsor of of
FIFA is Budweiser
a beer company which spent depending on
what numbers you look at somewhere
between 75 and 125 and 112 million
dollars to sponsor this and they're
they're kind of looking for a refund on
on this since you can't drink Budweiser
at the Budweiser sports ball game and
the uh you know the um the thing I was I
was really excited about were the were
these uh social media posts in which
they were showing photos of of people
like secreting in beer in Coca-Cola cans
that they'd like wrapped in like special
Coca-Cola things that make their their
like their pale ale look like a can of
Coke but apparently that's that's fake
news it's not real those photos were
actually from some other thing where
somebody needed to sneak beer into some
place still I admire the just like I
like the idea of a fan snake and beard I
did see an actual video that appears to
be real of a guy trying to sneak beer in
in a pair of binoculars that was
actually a flask that's that's pretty
cool work though pretty baller uh Nick
you have a love hate relationship with
International quadrennial sporting
events where do you where do you land on
with all of this soccer playing well
yeah uh you know I like soccer I was
playing soccer since 1969 uh back when
it was really a minority sport in
America and took a lot of abuse for that
as a kid and as a young adult
um I like soccer I hate watching it I
will merely say in qatar's defense uh
that FIFA is the most corrupt major
sports body on the planet which is
saying something but Qatar is probably
only the third worst host of a World Cup
uh because back in 1934 Italy under
Mussolini actually hosted the World Cup
and Italy went on to win they beat
Czechoslovakia Matt in that so that was
bad and then even more even worse and
more recently Argentina hosted in 78 a
couple years after a murderous brutal
military Hunter took over and actually
had used some of the stadiums that games
were played in to round up and torture
and kill political prisoners so cutter
which is merely a hotbed of completely
corrupt plutocrats that has had
something like 6 500 semi-slave workers
die over the past decade when it was
since it was awarded uh This World Cup
in 2010 by the
amazingly corrupt former leader of FIFA
sep bladder who's not allowed at World
Cup games because he is so [ __ ]
corrupt that even the World Cup is like
no you can't come here anymore uh so
cutter you know relatively speaking is
actually kind of a a good place for the
World Cup to be Catherine um what's your
favorite uh tidbit from this uh sports
ball tournament
I have become obsessed with FIFA
president Gianni Infantino who seems to
be I mean I guess the former guy was
even worse maybe but like every single
thing out of this man's face that I have
had the occasion to witness is just
horrific uh the quote from the first day
of the World Cup today I feel Qatari
today I feel Arabic today I feel African
today I feel gay today I feel disabled
okay
okay do you relate to any of that
Catherine me
wow
um but also uh him saying uh don't
criticize Qatar criticize FIFA if you
think that this beer thing is bad uh
criticized FIFA criticize me if you want
I am responsible for everything and then
he went on to do a little speech about
how since European colonialism was bad
it's fine that this soccer game is being
held in an authoritarian country and
everyone should shut up the the total
lack of like the very first thing you
learned when you were a child is like
two wrongs don't make a right my dude
like I just don't know how to explain
this more clearly I just love how
they're all named like absolute super
villains the FIFA heads oh yeah this is
not I mean like I I the simulation you
know Elon is busy elsewhere and so the
simulation is getting sloppier and
sloppier or whatever but um but yes just
this idea of sort of we we have this
Instinct right that like these Global
sporting events the Olympics are like
this too should somehow uh bring people
together and reward fair play and reward
what we perceive to be like good
behavior on the part of countries
um we need to let that idea go that is
not what is happening
um it is not what is gonna happen
unfortunately
um all the more reason for me to 10 that
none of this exists and go about my life
my favorite thing to watch so far in the
tournament uh besides the uh the
continued great play of France la blues
uh is uh the uh Japanese fans cleaning
up after each game that they watch their
team they're just like uh in the stands
with giant bags just cleaning the hell
out of the stadium and everyone's like
wow look at all these Japanese people
cleaning up it's just awesome it's fun
go check out the videos
um the other thing of interest uh that's
uh a little less uh light-hearted is
what's happening with the Iranian
national anthem uh the very first game
that Iran played against England I think
um the players did not sing it they sat
stone-faced and uh did not Mount the
words in silent protest of the just
god-awful Slaughter that's going on
there I mean hundreds of protesters have
been killed over the last six weeks in
Iran
um and uh and it's awful and uh and then
there was after this kind of well
publicized uh protest the second game
that they played they very very kind of
half-heartedly mouthed it and it was
became really obvious that a lot of
pressure was brought to bear on them and
the crowd was booing including of
Iranians who were there they wanted them
to not say it was just it's all like
this super fraught and uh highly tense
moment
um that's gonna play out again on
Tuesday when they play the United States
in a make or break uh go to the next
round or not uh game so it'll be
interesting to watch it's terrible that
humans are put in such a position
um and uh you know uh it's it's a really
awful to see the ongoing uh crackdowns
there and elsewhere we lived in a very
fraught time that's it that's the speech
um okay let's go to our end of podcast
what we're all watching consuming
reading and all this kind of stuff Nick
I saw on social media on Instagram a
pretty healthy review of a recent play
do you want to talk about it
sure I want to see the new David hair
drama uh he's a British playwright of
note of you know one of the best known
and highly most highly regarded uh
post-war uh uh writers from England but
he wrote a play that started there as
now in New York at the shed uh called
straight line crazy which is about
Robert Moses uh starring Ray fines and
so I went into this like Voldemort as
the power broker this is going to be you
know the story that has been told about
Robert Carro who uh excuse me not Robert
Carroll Robert Moses who since Robert
Cara's 1970 for biography the power
broker has been the villain in almost
every story about urban planning uh it's
always Robert Moses the evil power mad
monster versus Jane Jacobs the lovable
kind of amateur journalist and housewife
from who saved Greenwich Village from a
four-lane highway in the 60s the play is
great not because it is on Moses's side
but it does tell his side of the story
and his role in creating not just a New
York City New York metro area in New
York state that was filled with state
parks and a pretty thriving throughways
and highways that actually help things
move after World War before World War II
but especially after for a while but
also because it challenges some of Jane
Jacobs uh hagiography and she's a
character in it at one point which I
thought was deeply moving she
acknowledges that she left New York in
the late 60s for Toronto because she
didn't want her kids to be drafted and
she's uh she's portrayed wonderfully all
the acting is great but it's um she says
that you know she got her way and the
result was that Greenwich Village in
SoHo the places she was trying to save
became enclaves of the wealth of the
wealthy and the white and she asked
whether or not her vision of New York
City led to a city that is wider less
Dynamic and just for the rich or at
least Manhattan is she might be as
guilty as Robert Moses of the decline of
New York in the 1970s and a chunk of the
80s it's a fantastic play that is a
great meditation on power on the past on
Commerce on Race you name it fantastic
and Ray finds is really fantastic the
sad thing is it's a limited run the
theater seats about 200 people the
tickets are [ __ ] ridiculous they cost
like over 200 bucks you can only get
them on a secondary market and things
like that but it's a great story uh
extremely well told and I recommend I
hope it gets made into a movie or a
version of it is available for viewing
because uh if you believe in mostly free
cities with a little bit of planning but
not too much this is a great way of kind
of revisiting that conversation in a way
that I think a lot of Libertarians in
particular have been very quick to say
there should never be any kind of
planning above what a local Merchant or
you know a family decides to do with
their property very good stuff so
straight line crazy
I watched the first season of Star Wars
Andor on Disney plus it's fantastic
probably certainly my favorite Star Wars
thing of the Disney era and probably the
best Star Wars thing since Empire
Strikes Back so if the showrunner is is
Tony Gilroy who is one of the
masterminds behind the Bourne series
also uh was brought in to sort of fix up
Rogue one in the post-production process
and it's a prequel to Rogue one which of
course was about the the plot to steal
the Death Star plans but this is Star
Wars by way of the Bourne series by way
of Serial Thriller fiction by way of
kind of cynical British political drama
and what's really interesting are the
the political themes and the way it
brings out some of the kind of inherent
libertarian sensibility of the
uh Star Wars drama
um so there's like a criminal justice
angle in that there's a whole extended
bit about unjust and arbitrary
um prison sentences and the Empire using
them to build you know sort of its
Machines of War but what's really
interesting about this show is that it
recasts the Rebel Alliance first of all
as an alliance not just as a sort of
singular uh Rebellion with a clear
central government but just as a
decentralized movement with a bunch of
different groups with different
um in some ways different ideologies but
certainly different pain tolerances and
different willingnesses to uh to to act
in different ways right so some of them
are like no we have to protect citizens
others are like well you know what if
there was a little bit of extra violence
here that might not be so bad for our
cause uh others are just like well
actually I'm just in it for the money
and for myself and it really kind of
gets at the ways that a rebellion
against a tyrannical authoritarian
government would in fact draw in a bunch
of different types not just good
upstanding and you know sort of Freedom
loving anti-authoritarians at the same
time it really posits that the core of
the Rebellion is a bunch of good
upstanding anti-government types and
what's really fascinating is without I
think intending to it codes the
Rebellion which is of course the good
guys in maybe the single biggest uh IP
in pop culture in modern pop culture
history right it codes the good guys in
Star Wars as essential as essentially a
right-wing Freedom loving
anti-government types and the through
line throughout this 12 episode series
turns out to be funding and how do they
fund the rebellion and this is a
question we've never really like
encountered in Star Wars before we've
never really thought about it and it
turns out it's a whole bunch of dark
money non-profits yeah like run it's
it's a bunch of dark money non-profits
run uh run through a little bit through
Congress and a little bit through some
bankers who are maybe not the most
morally upstanding people but maybe also
have some good interests uh as in
addition to them being kind of selfish
and it's just like oh yeah oh right if
there were like a a system-wide
rebellion against a tyrannical
government there'd be some really good
people who you'd root for and there'd be
some kind of shady characters and
there'd be a lot of crazy money moving
that was like ah man
ah the New York Times found out about
that they would be very dubious
it's so great it's just the it's the
best Star Wars thing I I've seen as an
adult period can't recommend it enough
if you like Star Wars if you think you
have the capacity to like Star Wars uh I
look forward to now uh watching that
Peter Rogue one I appreciate it as like
the closest the Star Wars uh Universe
would come to making like a Guns of
Navarone movie
um you know with a kill switch problem
obviously I think Rogue one is the best
feature film of the Disney era but this
is much better than Rogue one and in
fact it makes Rogue one better uh
Catherine what have you been uh
consuming
well to be similarly on brand I guess uh
I've been watching uh the new adaptation
of Interview with the Vampire uh because
that's who I am as a person
um the 1994 adaptation absolutely formed
like a core part of my aesthetic and
identity in ways that I have yet to
fully unpack and
um as a result I am of mixed feelings
about the new version because when you
love the original you have mixed
feelings about the new version
um it's pretty good it's pretty good um
but I say this as someone who watched it
partially while um like kind of messed
up on Percocet shortly after uh injuring
myself I've continued to watch it um
it's not I think we've had seven of the
Eight Episodes
um of the first series it's already been
renewed for a second the most
interesting tidbit which I will
highlight is uh there's a lot more about
the kind of Commerce and life of of New
Orleans uh it's in Anne Rice's books
which I of course also read at a far too
young formative age it wasn't really in
the 1994 movie it is in the series
there's just more about like how are
they funding this existence is it just
like they do mind control and people
hand their cash not entirely
um I like that stuff I like the black
markets and the gray markets um because
they uh have sort of played more with
race in this series you have um some
interesting kind of implications from
that
um the biggest change is that uh Claudia
the the child vampire played by Kristen
Dunst in the movie She's 10 in the movie
she's five in the book she's 14 in this
series an interesting reflection I think
of our increasing squeamishness with
anything that remotely resembles
pedophilia maybe to our credit as a
society maybe not uh there's certainly
um it it hits different right it just
like really creates some very different
Dynamics both of the little explicitly
gay family uh that the vampires create
in this series uh and also
um how you're kind of reading that
character as a
um loss of innocent story Etc so
um the actors are very good the series
is very nicely made I personally will
never forgive it for not being the 1994
movie but your mileage may vary so
Interview with the Vampire it's an AMC
series you can uh stream it and catch up
in time for the last episode
so I saw along with my seven-year-old
um an exhibition here in New York City
uh called Beyond King Tut the immersive
experience
um it was great speaking of 1994 right
like wasn't like that about when the
King Tut thing was touring around 1977
where is this oh maybe there's another
round
the funky don't start with the Steve
Martin Erasure Catherine that's not
going to stand yeah so sorry uh with a
couple olds on your podcast uh no uh
it's
um I really enjoyed it very much and and
and uh like it I think Nick talked about
going to at least one
immersive experience type of exhibition
in New York over the past months
and I'm kind of intrigued by this as a
category I think it's the first one that
I went to that could be described in
that way
um as a category of Museum going so you
it's basically it's on pure 36 in the
East River
um Big Empty kind of Warehouse that they
divided up the rooms with various kind
of like screens and it's almost all
screens uh you walk in you start with
sort of a newsreel footage of uh King
Tut's tomb being discovered in 1922 by
Sir you know fuggledy-fugly uh whoever
did that
um and uh and then at the end he had
like a name that would allow him to be
the president of FIFA yeah absolutely
yes not quite uh Leonard pymph garnell I
think it was um
um another uh never stop SNL uh
sadly it's uh the archaeologist was
Howard Carter it's more like a MCU uh uh
TV series
um anyways uh so you watch a little
black and white thing that explains the
bit and then
um at the end of this thing suddenly
there's a door that appears in the
screen and you walk through it
um and it's just a nice exhibition a
very sort of uh audio visual that tells
you the history of finding the tomb
gives you the context of uh of the
discovery how it was very interesting
that it was it was one of the last uh
and only completely sort of sealed the
tombs that hadn't been ransacked that's
one of the reasons why I was so rich
um and you're going to a series of of uh
sort of displays and screens and then
you start getting into ever more
elaborate rooms where you're surrounded
on all sides uh like uh in a simulation
of the actual tomb room where the
sarcophagus was and this kind of
animated crazy stuff is going around you
in the walls and you realize after a
while that this is an exhibition or an
exhibit Without Really any artifacts
there's a couple of Recreations of some
famous chair they use the the support
games that they used to play but it kind
of uh solves or addresses in an
interesting way one of the uh the
squeamish making things about
archaeological exhibits which is that
they have to steal things
the grave robbing to put a little grave
robbing aspect of it
um uh speaking of which that if you
haven't uh you should go see the Holy
Land exhibition in Silver Lake
California if it still exists that's a
crazy place but table that for a moment
um uh it's it it ends up being exhibit
with very little uh artifacts and but it
gives you this uh experience of it uh
using in often times
um kind of animated hieroglyphics they
take the existing uh art from it and
I've noticed this I've watched them a
lot in documentaries that I've been
watching with uh with my kid about
ancient Egypt and ancient uh Greece and
stuff like that they use uh uh the
existing art and they animate it in a
useful way to to portray scenes that we
wouldn't otherwise be able to see and it
just becomes it affects you in a whole
body way that uh seeing stolen artifacts
might not necessarily get you to
um really great uh takes about uh 60
Minutes 90 minutes a little virtue
reality thing there it's too expensive
um and at the end when you go to the
gift store because you haven't actually
seen any artifacts you suddenly feel
like buying stuff uh which is an
interesting uh tidbit too
um but anyways
um it's a gift
um for uh my uh my wife's uh uh Aunt
um uh like a cat that doesn't sound true
um yeah no it sounds like some kind of
weird sexual does the exhibition get
into this over this over the possibly
secret hidden rooms they haven't uh that
they have not uncovered yet which may or
may not exist uh or the curse curse that
element there's no secret room element
um they do talk a little bit about a
thing
um which is the fascinating that Tut
exists in this you know he has his
kingdom was from age 9 to 19 and then he
croaked
um and He restored polytheism
um which is part of the kind of Secret
of or explanation for why
um he doesn't really appear in a lot of
histories
um because his successor and this wasn't
in the exhibit the other stuff that I've
consumed recently the successor uh
really wanted to there wasn't an obvious
successor so he wanted to seal the deal
they closed that tomb when the paint was
still wet
um uh and so he wanted to take power but
also seal the deal of restoring
polytheism because Tut's dad
um had made this radical thing of like
okay screw the rest of the Gods and all
the snakes and stuff like that we're
just gonna have a sun god name raw and
that's it and we're gonna move the
capital and it was very big radical idea
a.m so did they move the capital today
and that's how we ended up with the
great uh Jazz composer son raw and his
orchestra that is absolutely correct
yeah um all right
uh Matt that seems like a good opening
to talk about right
uh one of your favorite uh Southern
California
musicians coomb critics of uh uh and of
U.S uh Cuba policy
um but sadly we don't have much more
time for any of that but we're going to
have a lot of more content for you this
week I'm gonna have a bonus uh uh
podcast as uh referenced uh Nick what
what are we teeing up aren't we doing
some kind of a live thing later this
week
yeah we're gonna have a uh live webathon
Telethon live stream on Thursday from 1
p.m Eastern Time to 3 P.M eastern time
it's going to be an immersive experience
Matt you'll be watching on your computer
but you're going to feel pretty Dirty by
the end of it are you going to restore
polytheism or at least Catherine's
polycule you know
I don't know that it was ever gone I
guess we are going to bring back belief
in some Gods but not all we are all as
God's neck
uh yes and we also have if I may a
wonderful event in New York City uh the
greatest city in the world or what
remains of it after Jane Jacobs and
Robert Moses teamed up to ruin it in the
mid 60s uh a reason Speak Easy with
Caitlin Bailey who is the head of Old
Pros a sex worker right group that seeks
to decriminalize and destigmatize sex
work
um that is happening in New York City in
Midtown at the blue building a great uh
venue for ten dollars you get beer wine
soda soft drinks and more conversation
than you'll ever want to have at go to
reason.com events to get details and to
show up and be edified and entered all
right thanks everyone for listening I'm
going to be doing a lot of webathoning
with you people for the rest of the week
just get those last emails in the
deadlines coming up uh Roundtable at
reason.com do it all right goodbye
see you try
[Music]